LES: So welcome to our hangout
for Google TV. Let's shoot.
I'll start with Will.
We know that he's
gonna at least
have a technical question.
WILL: Oh.
LES: Or not.
I can move on.
WILL: I tried to put marketing
questions in my list today.
LES: OK, that's cool.
WILL: Let me get to your post.
LES: OK, maybe I can get
reminded [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
scroll down there too.
Let's see, you asked
app review hangout?
WILL: Oh yeah, that was just me
trying to promote myself.
We were thinking with Google TV
friends about doing an app
review, hangout type of thing.
For developers who wanted to
just talk about their app.
Kinda patterned after,
there's an Android
developer one that I saw.
It started last Friday.
It looked pretty cool.
And it would be fun to do one
specifically for Google TV, so
that was just me saying,
wondering if anyone would be
interested to talk to myself
and [INAUDIBLE]
Chris.
OSAMA: That's a good idea.
Maybe we should theme
one of these
hangouts as an app review.
LES: Yeah, cause we do app
reviews pretty regularly too.
So we could give some guidance
and some help.
WILL: Cool.
LES: And maybe that's what
Christian could do next week
while I'm away.
WILL: Sounds good.
OSAMA: Awesome.
LES: OK, let's see.
I see Chris on there,
so he could probably
have similar stuff.
And I hate my cursor.
Ah, cool.
All right, then I'm gonna
go to the next person.
Magnus, you have a question?
Or not.
OK.
Chris, do you have
any questions?
CHRIS: Just one.
It's pretty much back to the
market issues again.
Two things.
One is still the downloading of
the apps or the uploading
of the apps just doesn't work.
And the other one is you can't
leave a review of an app from
the Google TV. At least
I can't, using
the Logitech reviews.
It just doesn't work.
LES: Does it error out, or?
CHRIS: No.
I can't enter anything into the
boxes, and then when I do
it's all capitals.
And if I mess up, there's no way
to backspace, delete the
text, so it's just there.
And I either have to cancel, and
if I submit it, it's just
gonna look all messed up.
But that may be just
on my device.
So I have to go back onto the
laptop, go into the market,
leave a review that way.
I can't do it through the TV.
LES: OK, we know people
are doing reviews.
You're welcome to join us, AK.
Yes, come on in.
OK, so I'll take a look.
I don't think we've recieved
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
like that before.
But, yeah, and you wouldn't
have a Sony
box or just a Review?
CHRIS: Just the Review.
LES: OK.
Cool.
All right.
Then we'll take a look.
That's a problem in the market
that you can't leave reviews
on a Review.
So I'll move on to Dustin.
DUSTIN: OK, my question was in
regards to the in-app billing.
And I'd like to switch from the
developer account on the
Review over to the test account
that we set up, but I
don't see an easy way of doing
that without factory resetting
the device.
LES: Can't you just add another
account and use that
for your market account?
You go into Settings, then
Accounts, and Add Account.
OSAMA: And then in market--
DUSTIN: Honestly, I haven't
tried, so--
OSAMA: You can switch
the primary account.
LES: Yeah.
That would be how you'd do it.
DUSTIN: OK.
Great, thanks.
LES: OK.
Cool.
DUSTIN: Easy.
LES: Yeah.
Brian, you're next.
Do you have a question?
OK.
You can type it into the
chat window too.
And Brad had a couple points
and questions.
BRAD: Hey guys, it's Brad
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Sorry it's kind of dark.
But I guess my first question
was obviously at some point,
we're gonna see whatever you
want to call it, fragmentation
or units left behind.
Is that going to happen with the
Review on 3.2 or is that
gonna get updated?
I know you can't tell us when,
and I know there's politics
and other things involved
in that.
But is it gonna see the
HLS capability--
LES: Yes.
BRAD: That we have now?
LES: Yeah, the reviews
will see HLS.
BRAD: OK.
So they're gonna get the
full 3.2 update?
LES: Yes.
BRAD: OK.
So obviously that brings some
functionality that I know a
lot of Review users
will find useful.
Obviously with, for streaming
video and things that'll bring
a lot of capability.
LES: Oh yeah.
BRAD: So that's pretty
important.
LES: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
BRAD: I had another question
and I don't
remember what it is now.
It's been a couple days.
LES: OK, that's cool.
We'll come back.
BRAD: But that's really great.
I appreciate you letting
us know that
that will get updated.
CHRISTIAN: Have you mentioned
the SDK level, 12, 13?
BRAD: Oh!
I asked something about the--
I'm sorry, it was
about the NDK.
LES: I have at times.
Yes sure, there's no NDK
for now and not for the
foreseeable future.
BRAD: OK.
LES: Is there anything else
you are concerned
about the NDK about?
BRAD: Well, I guess my question
was that it appeared
that OnLive may have used some
kind of NDK functionality to
write their app.
And I could be wrong, is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] what I said.
LES: There are some people who
have figured out how to get
native code on Google TV.
And they are in market.
It is--
CHRISTIAN: So, I mean--
LES: not compatible with
anything, and there's no
guarantees.
And it will break soon.
BRAD: OK.
OSAMA: As with any undocumented
APIs, we
recommend you don't use them.
And we may change those at any
point, so your apps may break.
BRAD: That's understood.
LES: The app will break.
We actually know
that as a fact.
BRAD: Yeah, I guess the only
reason I ask, Les, is because
I know that sometimes some
developers get early access to
things because they
are big time
developers like OnLive is.
And I know that there's a
partnership with OnLive
bringing the the gaming to
Google TV, so I just was
wondering if they got a preview
view of an NDK, and it
was coming sooner.
Because I know that I've
listened to every hang out,
and you've said multiple
times no NDK right now,
no NDK right now.
But it just looked
like they were
utilizing some native code.
LES: [INAUDIBLE] me now.
Yep.
OK.
Yeah, no there is no, there's
no seeding of an NDK at this
point, because we can't
have an NDK.
And I can't really explain
it too much today.
BRAD: That's fair.
LES: OK, I'm going to
move, as soon I find
my cursor, to Amir.
Do you have a question?
Or you could just type it into
the chat window if you'd like.
I'm gonna move on to
Alexander, and
then I'll come back.
ALEXANDER: Hey.
LES: Hi.
ALEXANDER: I was wondering, I
posted my question up on your
original post ages ago, what do
you think the legitimacy of
using console style controllers,
or using PS3 or
XBox 360 controllers
with Google TV
will be in the future?
Do you think it's something we
should look at for games in
particular?
LES: So, you mean
the controllers?
ALEXANDER: Mmhmm.
LES: Just everyone remember
to mute your mics
when you're not on.
Cause we're hearing some
feedback somewhere.
Christian?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
CHRISTIAN: Right now, the
controllers out there are the
ones that are out there.
For the new generation TVs that
were shown at CES, the
OEMs are experimenting with
new generation of remote
controls They are not final
yet, and we haven't really
seen anything really
reliable there.
I think what's possible is,
people can plug in USB
controllers.
We've experimented a little bit
with basically plugging in
USB game console controllers.
It's OK.
It's workable, the USB drivers
will recognize it.
But the challenge is that--
I'm trying to make room here--
your users may or may not have
the same game controllers that
you have. And it gets, I wanna
say you limit your audience a
little bit.
So I would say at this point,
the best is just rely on the
controllers that come with
the devices, with the
Review or the Sony.
Or another alternative is we
really would love to see
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
as remote controls
but we've also seen some
developers that have
successfully written
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
remote control.
Then you can use gyros and all
kinds of stuff with it.
LES: OK.
I'm going to go on to
Will's question.
I muted Alexander just cause
we were picking up stuff.
And Will was asking about
in-app billing.
WILL: OK.
I'm working on in-app billing
right now today with my app
and I'm not stuck, really.
But my question is, I have it
basically working where I can
charge myself and I can see
the charge in the console.
So that's working.
But my idea then is to just
write to a flag and a shared
preference to say that this
purchase was made.
And then rely on that flag
within my app to behave
differently based on a
purchase situation.
So is that OK to use?
Is that what I should
be using to do that?
Could somehow you could change
the shared preferences packet
somehow to find that flag
and say I've paid.
That's my first question,
and then--
LES: Well, you can think
of it as a cache.
So if the flag is there, again
people could try to defeat you
by, they could try to defeat
that, but you can think of it
as a flash.
And if it's not there, rather
than assume that it's not
paid, you might want to
request of the license
verification library.
WILL: Right, yes.
LES: [INAUDIBLE] somebody.
And see, there's two kinds
of in-app billing.
There are permanent licenses,
which is probably what you're
gonna want to use.
And there's also temporary
licenses, which is for game
[? components ?]
to get reused.
WILL: I gotcha, OK.
LES: That are expendable.
And so you use the flag
to begin with just for
performance reasons.
Which actually probably isn't
that significant on a TV. And
then you use the license
verification library.
WILL: OK.
All right, yeah.
I'm just sort of getting into
it today, so that was, I
wasn't particularly stuck.
But I wanted to throw a
technical question out there,
so thank you.
LES: All right.
Let's see.
Does anybody have a question?
We've also been joined, we
have AK, who's one of our
project managers.
And Vincent, who founded
the Google TV project.
Is that a good introduction?
VINCENT: We can give-- hi,
LES: Let's get Vincent.
VINCENT: I'm Vincent.
That's OK.
KIM: AK, I'm Kim.
VINCENT: Oh, we don't
mind hiding.
LES: Think we're good.
VINCENT: That's all right.
Don't worry.
AK: Hi, I'm AK.
I'm hiding on the side here.
LES: Yeah, so if you've
got any--
AK's really the one, actually
both of them are good ones to
talk about what you want with.
You know, features you'd like.
Not features that are
coming, but so if
you have any of those.
And--
BRAD: Hey Wes?
LES: Yes?
BRAD: Real quick.
In the past you had mentioned
that you were gonna check in
to seeing if the market
could be updated
outside a firmware update.
Obviously, we all know the
market has a bunch of issues.
Been able to find that out?
And I know that you said
there's a lot of people
working on getting--
SPEAKER 1: I think before we
talk about the market,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I think market could
be operationally a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
outside of the [? OPA. ?]
But what kind of issues do you
have with market right now
that we should fix?
BRAD: I think a lot of us feel
that there's probably some UI
issues, but also it doesn't
show the installed apps.
A lot of times it has trouble
updating apps.
A lot of times, let's see.
Installed, let's see.
It doesn't show installed apps,
has issue updating apps.
I know that I personally had
some issues with paid failures
just failing out, so I just
[INAUDIBLE] the market's got
some issues that probably
need to be rethought.
And I thought that Les had
mentioned that you guys were
looking, that there was people
working on that.
SPEAKER 1: They're actively
fixing bugs
in those areas also.
You would likely see an update
whether through an [? OPA ?]
or through other means.
You would see an update, but I
can't talk about timelines.
BRAD: Yep.
No, understood that you can't
talk about timelines.
LES: What he was asking though,
is can market be done
through other means
besides an OTA?
SPEAKER 1: You could put
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] outside of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
As it is done on
phones as well.
BRAD: Right.
Well, that's good because I hate
to see, especially the
Logitech side of the house.
Obviously, those guys are a
little slower with their OTAs
than other people.
Hate to see a market delay.
SPEAKER 1: At the end of the
day, the question is, are we
gonna keep updating market?
And the answer is yes.
LES: OK.
I think we're--
BRAD: Thank you.
LES: Are there any other
live questions?
Or I can start reading some.
Ah, Amir is back.
AMIR: Yes, can you hear me?
LES: Yes.
AMIR: All right, so my question
comes with the
arrival of the ARMADA1500 Google
TVs that are hitting
the market.
And the fact that it's just the
ARM CPU that's coming out.
My question comes in to the
people, the early adopters who
had purchased the Reviews and
the Sony line of devices.
Are we going to be left out
when, if you all do decide to
enable native code?
Because I mean I heard you all
mention just recently that
native code will break.
Of course it's gonna break cause
you're gonna be on a
different architecture.
But I'm assuming the reason
y'all are going to the other
architecture is so that you can
enable that native code
and expand the marketplace to
a wider, bring in a wider
marketplace to the TVs. Because
right now it's kind of
being hurt by the fact that the
developers aren't really
siding y'all's way right now.
SPEAKER 1: Some of this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is dependent on the OEMs,
as you've seen in
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
We would want most of these
devices to be updated, but a
lot of it is dependent on OEMs.
It's difficult for us to
predict how different devices
would get updated.
AMIR: Well, it's not really
updating, because it seems
like the Google TV platform is
moving to an ARM architecture.
So I mean, my main question
is do you leave the early
adopters out in the dust when
this new line of Google TV
devices come out?
Because we're all
gonna be on X86.
We may get a lack of updates, we
may get poor market support
if you do choose to enable
native code.
Just along those lines.
It's not really anything that
you could really change, other
than having some type of low
level bytecode emulator.
But I mean, I was just looking
for some hope.
SPEAKER 2: We have this
bytecode emulator.
We call it a Dalvik
virtual machine.
AMIR: Right.
LES: It works really well.
SPEAKER 3: The question
is, so--
AMIR: I'm talking about
native code.
SPEAKER 3: in general, as we
shift new devices on the
market, what about the earlier
generation devices, right?
AMIR: Right, right.
SPEAKER 3: So on our end,
obviously what we want to do
is, we want to keep those
devices alive
as long as we can.
AMIR: Right.
SPEAKER 3: We have
two dependencies.
We have one dependency
on Intel, or whoever
builds the chip set.
AMIR: Right.
SPEAKER 3: And another
dependency is on, in this
particular case, Sony
and Logitech.
AMIR: Right.
SPEAKER 3: And so
we need support.
Depending on how much we do,
we need support from either
one of them, which would
be Logitech or Sony.
Or in some cases, both Logitech
and Intel to continue
to support the platform.
AMIR: I see everything moving
to ARM, and it seems like a
platform decision, as opposed
to a OEM decision.
'Cause I mean, I don't see any
more X86 second generation
Google TVs. It seems like
that's almost dead.
SPEAKER 3: It's not our
migration to, I mean, the fact
that the new generation devices
are ARM based, I don't
think you should read it
as a platform decision.
It's really, we were actually
guided by the OEMs who
actually built those, who were
building those second
generation devices.
So they're the ones who made the
decision in terms of which
chips that they're using.
It's the guys that use the
chipset that decided which CPU
they're using.
That's really how it happened.
And as Christian pointed out,
you should think of Android,
Android is a virtual machine.
It has a bytecode interpreter
precisely so that we can stay
away from those CPU
dependencies.
AMIR: But am I or am I not
correct that that's
only for Java code?
The native code still has
to be compiled to the
architecture.
SPEAKER 2: That's partially
correct.
So I mean, we really recommend
using Android right now, and
using the Java code in
Android, of course.
But if you want really high
performance in your
application, I would really
like you to take a look at
Renderscript.
It's very close to C code.
It's very efficient, and it gets
executed directly on the
graphics hardware.
So if you do any visual effects
or anything in games,
we've seen a lot of good
performance actually in
Renderscript.
For business logic type
applications, things that you
really do more like a UI and
input output operations,
Dalvik is really an
excellent choice.
It makes it very easy to have
compelling user interfaces and
compelling apps.
I know there is a lot of people
who have legacy code,
and who want to use basically
native Intel
or uncompiled libraries.
That's one of the areas we are
aware of, but unfortunately,
there is really not much
that we can do.
And as Vincent pointed out,
the consumer electronics
market is really very heavily
driven by the audience.
If they make a chipset decision
based on their needs
and requirements, that was one
of the reasons why Android was
invented, so to speak.
Is really to enable developers
to create applications across
a broad range of different
consumer electronic devices.
AMIR: That's very fair.
And I do understand that ARM
chips are generally cheaper
than anything Intel puts out.
So I do understand the cost
aspect that we all saw with
the price drop of the Review and
the Sony devices, that you
all have to stay competitive.
Which means going to
those ARM chips.
I have another question that's
not related to that.
But it is a time
frame question.
You said you didn't
want those?
LES: Well, ask it, and I'll tell
you if we can't do it.
AMIR: OK, that's fair.
Really I was just looking to
see if there's progress or
really if there's consideration
on seeing
extensions on the Google
TV anytime soon?
LES: You mean, extensions,
you mean--
AMIR: Chrome extensions,
I'm sorry.
LES: Chrome extensions.
AMIR: Yes sir.
SPEAKER 1: No plan
yet on those.
AMIR: OK.
LES: By the way, you and
I are the only two who
have asked for that.
SPEAKER 3: Well actually, I
mean I think that from a
philosophical point of view, I
thing we need to worry about
consumers, right?
So if we provide too many
application frameworks that
also means that at the same
time, integration is not gonna
be seamless.
So that means that, I ran into
that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
issue, which is, you can create
a webapp, you can
create an Android app.
If you want to get to the
webapp, you go one way.
The Android app,
the other way.
We tried to do a few things to
make that more seamless, but
it's still different, right?
So if we create yet another
application framework, which
is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
enabled on the platform, which
is called extensions.
Which by the way, competes also
with Android Widgets in a
way, that for users it's gonna
be really, really confusing.
They'll get different
experiences depending on what
we chose, what you guys chose
as the application
environment.
I mean, I already
get confused.
The other day, I was looking
for TuneIn Radio, and I
couldn't figure out why
it was not on Market.
It's because, as a
user, I didn't
remember it was a webapp.
And why should I remember,
right?
So I think that at the end of
the day we don't support
Chrome extensions because it's
work, frankly speaking.
But even if it was not a lot of
work, I think we'd have to
think hard before we enabled
yet another application
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AMIR: Well, you did mention, I
heard Les mention that he was
one of the only ones that
had asked for it.
But this probably won't make the
content providers happy,
but I am really just looking for
Adblock Plus on my Google
TV. As when I visit sites the
performance of the Chrome
browser is just really
lacking.
And I don't know if it's the
box, or anything else.
But I feel like getting rid of
some of these motion banners
and video ads and whatnot
would definitely help.
LES: You'll see an improvement
when you get the update.
AMIR: The 3.2?
LES: Yes.
AMIR: OK.
LES: Chrome is a little
bit zippier.
But we understand what
you're interested in.
I'm going to move on to a couple
of written questions.
Steve Whitney asks about input
options for his apps on Google
TV. It would be really helpful
to know what the possibilities
are in terms of input devices.
Will we always have touchpads,
arrow keys, alphanumeric
keyboards, et cetera?
Will the keys always be
arranged the same way?
I'd like to assign keys in
logical ways, layout wise,
that won't break
future devices.
Hi Vincent!
Aren't you glad you came?
VINCENT: Yeah.
Don't do that.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I think input device for TVs
is really not a science.
I think at this stage, it's
really interesting when we
look at user feedback.
It's very polarized.
Believe it or not, there
are people who love
the Logitech keyboard.
And there are people who love
the Sony keyboard, and there's
a lot of people who hate both.
And so we made it clear that
we're gonna keep experimenting
with device manufacturers
about the input devices.
So if that happens, going deep
and making assumptions, in
particular about locations of
keys, and I understand why you
would want to do that from a
usability standpoint, but I
think that at this stage, I
think it'd be really, really
premature to make that
kind of optimization.
LES: On that front, are we
going to publish our
requirements documents
that we give to OEMs?
Android publishes their
requirements so that
developers can know what's
direction of [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 1: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
direct requirements.
That [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
really is for OEMs.
LES: Right, but it's still
published so that developers
can look at it and figure out,
this is an area I can go into
and where I can't.
There are certainly stuff in
ours that developers would
find interesting.
SPEAKER 1: So I'm not sure if
we publish the requirement
documents [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
But what we can do is, we
can publish some type of
developers, on our
developer page.
On where things are going.
So as we have these things made,
we can put it on our
developer page.
LES: OK, we'll take
that offline, and
I'll come see you.
All right.
And any time any of you have
a question there, speak up.
But I'm gonna read from the
various written questions for
a little bit.
OK, there's a question
about ESPN and ESPN3.
OSAMA: That's not really
a developer question.
LES: It's not really a developer
question, and it's
not really anything we can do.
Let's see.
SPEAKER 2: So maybe, while you
find another question, just
dovetailing into the last user
input device question.
Do we have any information
that we want to share yet
about international
input devices?
So I would assume QWERTY
is very US centric.
So if Google TV launches in
different regions, I would
imagine that for example, the
basic keyboard layout of the
QWERTY keyboard is also going
to be adapted, right?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, but that
will happen [INAUDIBLE].
It's not [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and
definitely that's not, should
be trans-- well, yeah so.
SPEAKER 2: Should be, but if
somebody relies for game input
that whatever, the Z
is in the corner--
SPEAKER 3: That's a good point,
they need to worry
about that.
LES: Yeah, that's why they,
that was what that earlier
question about formatting, is to
figure out what they should
do for games.
And because we already have that
developers do one thing
for the Sony controller
and something
else for the Logitech.
SPEAKER 3: Well then, but even
more so to your point, I mean
definitely as far as the letter
part of the keyboard,
definitely there'd
be some impact
depending on the locale.
As I said, in general for the
time being, the physical
location of the mandatory keys
on the keyboard is gonna be
something relatively
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
LES: We have a question from
Alexander [? Kolychev ?]
asking about, he'd like to be
able to download the IOS
remote app from outside
the US.
Currently, it's region locked.
And I sent you an email
about that earlier.
SPEAKER 1: It's been removed.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Today [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
device in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
US, and that's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
LES: And then Jeff Deskines
asks about the issues of
designing websites for Google
TV versus apps.
OSAMA: So I think both are great
approaches for getting
content on TV. In general, if
you want the discoverability
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
features of Android market,
you should build Android
applications.
So that users discover apps in
one of two ways currently.
There's the spotlight section
on Google TV and there's
Android market.
In general, Android market is
more familiar to users who are
just approaching the TV. And
there's more, we found people
go to Android market first. So
if you want an app to get as
much visibility as possible,
I'd recommend
launching in Android.
LES: Yeah.
But if you already have a
website, it's not difficult to
adapt it to Google TV. We have
two libraries for one
extension to jQuery that will
let you quickly add d-pad
navigation to your website.
And if you're interested go to
developers.google.com/tv/web.
SPEAKER 1: And it's also
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I mean, if all your expertise
is in web and you only are
doing web, it's probably easier
for you to stay with
web rather than
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's probably a little bit of
a personal decision also, in
terms of what's easiest for
you to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SPEAKER 4: So what about having
your cake and eat it
too, which is developing an
Android app that's just a big
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
OSAMA: Yeah, so we've seen
a lot of good Android
applications that are
a hybrid of the two.
So they use WebView,
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
typically to build out
their user interface.
One great example of this
is the Redux app.
And then they delegate to
Android framework for things
like video playback.
It's very easy with the WebView
to have callbacks that
tie into Android
and vice versa.
So if you do have expertise in
web development, and already
have a code base, you can still
leverage the features of
Android market by building
this sort of hybrid
application.
LES: Yeah, there are some tricks
to WebView that make it
challenging.
The back button doesn't
always behave well.
OSAMA: Yeah, I mean it's things
that you have to test.
But if you already have the HTML
site, then it goes a long
way to building an app
and launching it.
LES: OK, so Bill Bradley asks
about is Android and Google TV
going to converge into
a single platform?
I doubt if anybody wants
to take that, but I'll
throw it out there.
OSAMA: I think, let's
stay away from any--
LES: Futures.
OSAMA: future questions.
LES: OK.
Bradley, actually we covered
Bradley's question about
Android market.
Actually Will's got some
marketing questions.
Do you want to ask those live?
WILL: Yeah.
Yeah, I will.
First one is about once you make
your app free, there's no
going back.
And I'm wondering if that can
be changed in the future?
So maybe it could support if
you had a special over the
weekend, maybe your app was
specific to a holiday, you
want to do something on that day
to make it free, and then
be able to go back and forth.
That'd be something I'd be
interested to know, if it was
going to be possible.
I also have an idea for an
app, but I think it has
copyright issues, and
I'm not sure.
I'm not a lawyer, so I don't
know how it works, but it has
to do with video.
I can't say anything, because I
signed an NDA, but is there
someone I could talk to there?
Or can you give me a resource
that I could ask to say, is
this illegal?
Is this idea illegal?
LES: We can't answer
that that way.
We can give you some non-legal
advice, but we can't give you
legal advice.
WILL: All right, I just, I'm
pretty ignorant on copyright
law, so it'd be like--
JOHN: This is John Blossom.
I'm not a lawyer, but if you
need somebody to bounce things
off of, just drop me a line.
WILL: OK.
Appreciate it, that's cool.
I've gotta check it out with my
partner, but I will be in
contact with you.
And I think the last one I
really cared about was a guy
reviewed my app recently.
And he seems to be, in his
review, he was talking about
problems with his hardware, but
he really took it out on
the app, and he gave it
a one star review.
And basically it was my free
version, there was no way I
could help him or respond to
him, as far as I could tell.
So I was hoping there'd be a
way that I could help the
person who has a problem
maybe, in that way, and
encourage him don't rate
me, rate the hardware.
Just some sort of--
OSAMA: It's good feedback.
It's good feedback that both you
and other people have. I
mean, it's just general Android
feedback on Android market.
So we understand that developers
want a way to
respond to reviews.
But that's all I can
say about that.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
market [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
get your feedback in
there, so it's--
WILL: How about the going
back and forth
between free and paid?
Will that be something
that'll be in there?
LES: Being able to give a
special, it certainly should
be a feature market, but that's
really taking it to
market team.
WILL: OK, thank you.
OSAMA: We'll give them that
feedback as well.
WILL: All right.
I appreciate it.
LES: OK, I'm gonna go on to--
are there any other
live questions?
OK, I'm gonna go on to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
TV asked about send system
logs check box.
Basically, and using the
read logs permission.
And wondering about, every time
you ask for a permission,
you should explain to your
users why you want it.
That's in Android
best practices.
And in the case of read logs,
since it's possible that
another app, not yours, might
make the mistake of putting
personal information in the log
file, you really should
encrypt it before you
send it to you.
But explain it to your users and
ask them for permission.
They're granting that
permission.
Ask it in a way that that
permission is separate, and
you bring it out.
And your users will
like you better.
And let them decline and
still run your app.
Christian?
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, I'm not a big
fan of read logs, but I agree
with your answer.
I mean, if the app really
requires it there better be a
good reason for it.
And explaining it to the
user makes sense.
LES: Let's see.
OK.
Michael [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
asks a whole bunch of questions
that really come
down to overlaying
live television.
And my rule is I'm happy to talk
about that, but I'm not
going to talk about
with you not here.
So join the hangout.
OSAMA: We've also, you probably
heard of this last
week, but based on feedback
we did launch a
public issue tracker.
And a place where you can go
file feature requests.
So I believe that feature
request is
already filed for there.
And you can find it on
developers.google.com/tv. It's
on the left side,and I have no
issues that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Yeah, but we heard this a
lot from many different
developers.
But we're hoping that interested
developers go to
the issue tracker, and
if the issue isn't
there, file the issue.
If the issue is there,
star the issue.
That way we can get a better
idea of how many developers
are interested in the
specific features.
And of the list of features,
which ones we should
prioritize.
It will also enable us to to
reach out at the developers
who are interested.
So when we do launch the
feature, if we do launch the
feature, we can let you know.
Or if we want some feedback
from developers on how to
build a feature, we can
reach out to you.
So please do use that
issue tracker.
It is something we do
take seriously when
prioritizing features.
LES: And a gentleman with
an Islamic name.
And I do not read Arabic,
so I will--
OSAMA: Arabic name.
LES: Arabic name, excuse me.
OSAMA: Are we going to have
VPM for Google TV?
LES: That's right,
you can read it.
OSAMA: I can't read Arabic.
LES: Oh, OK.
Yeah, that's really not
something that's probably a
big feature, but as Osama
just mentioned--
OSAMA: I'm sure it's maybe
something that an app
developer can do
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
LES: Is that your name, Amir?
OK.
Yeah, OK.
Let's see, plug for
the hangout.
We've already had a
question on that.
OSAMA: Yeah, I do
like that idea.
I did hear very positive
feedback about the Android--
VINCENT: What's the idea?
OSAMA: The Android did
basically a feature
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
went through apps that they
liked and they didn't like,
and apps that were suggested to
them and then gave feedback
based on what could make
this app better?
What could take it to the
finish line of being a
featured app?
So that's something I think that
we probably wanna run in
one of these hangouts.
And certainly, if you wanna do
it as a community thing, I'd
encourage you guys to do it.
LES: OK, at South by Southwest
we're going be talking about
some experimental
tools to access
high res YouTube videos.
And there should be
a public invite.
It's not an after party.
And it is at Eisenhower's.
There will be a whole section
of Google stuff at
Eisenhower's.
And in that neighborhood there's
like four buildings,
restaurants that we're
taking over.
Bars.
There will be a--
OSAMA: I believe it does
require a South by
Southwest pass, or?
LES: No.
OSAMA: It doesn't?
OK.
LES: It's basically you come.
The event that I'm talking about
is an invite only, but
there is a link to a
request an invite.
But the bar is open.
OSAMA: Where is the link?
LES: I don't know.
It's the Google South
by Southwest page.
And then we are also gonna
have open office hours.
Fifteen minutes, you can ask any
developer relations person
there any question you
want for 15 minutes.
Everything from technical
questions, marketing
questions, how do I get
hired at Google?
I want to join developer
relations, we'll talk
to you about it.
OK, any other live questions?
I don't know about the League of
Extraordinary Hackers event
with Chris [? Last. ?]
OK, live questions?
SPEAKER 5: It's not technical,
but did anybody invite Leon?
It's very uncommon for him
not to be here today.
LES: Yeah, he's on my invite, so
yeah, I was surprised he's
not here today.
But I know what he's working on,
so I expect that he's busy
working on that.
SPEAKER 5: And then, as far as
Will, with his app there, you
should just do what most of the
other top developers do.
They put a big note right on the
description page of their
app saying if you have issues,
contact you first before you
leave a bad review.
WILL: Yeah.
Yep.
SPEAKER 5: I didn't see that
on your description page.
I just saw your Google
Plus profile.
WILL: Yep, that's a
really good idea.
I'm gonna update my description
very shortly, actually.
That's gonna be part
of it, so.
LES: All right, I will give a
plug for, I'm doing events in
New York and in Toronto.
There's a public event
in Toronto, two
public events in Toronto.
If you're there, please
sign up and come.
Oh, have there been talks
about devices
with open boot loaders?
There haven't been talks
about these things.
That's good.
All right, any other
questions?
Going, going.
Thanks everyone for coming.
We'll call [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
early.
OSAMA: Thanks guys.
SPEAKER 3: Thanks guys.
LES: Oh, I betcha I
didn't do that.
I'm here.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Let's see.
Close.